how to contact big companies so I got a
great question for one of my youtube
viewers love you guys
JM young who wrote in to say hi Evan we
already have a product a proven market
and sales for our invention we're
patent-pending heck we move forward with
contacting the right people and the
companies who wish the license or sell
the invention - we have two major
companies in mind for invention Thanks
so it's a great question again to my
readers and you know as an inventor your
dream is to be able to sell your company
to a huge company where you get your big
payday and it can be a lot of struggling
along the way so how do you get in touch
with that big company so two key ways
that I hope will work for you and they
work in tandem with each other the first
is get connected I don't recommend going
out and just cold calling all these
companies and saying hey you know I'm JM
young from this company and I have this
great product view because these guys
are getting pitched all the time
right so that's not how you're gonna
stand out and even if you do get a
response you have no leverage right if
you get to negotiate it you want to get
good terms especially if you only have
two companies you can talk to you're
gonna have zero leverage with them
because you went to them asking first
sale so it's getting connected the first
thing I would do is go to my LinkedIn
now go to LinkedIn and I would type in
the company name and ideally a type of
position that you're looking forward to
connecting to because these big
companies tons of employees and see if
you know anybody who's connected to
somebody there or if not directly is
there a second or third connection you
can try to make your way into it and if
you have anybody then I wouldn't send
that LinkedIn email and saying hey can
you please connect me to your friend I
would call them up I would call up my
friend and say hey I'm trying to get
into you know Microsoft wherever company
it is I see you know this person on
LinkedIn is there any way that you could
connect me might make it personal
because everybody's getting bombarded on
LinkedIn with these invitation requests
okay so make it personal and get their
advice and get them involved so they
want to share your story and help you
out the second thing I'll do in a
connection side is I would look for
people who with their
my knees may be connected to the company
you're trying to get into so a great
example is your patent attorney when
you're you're going for patent your
patent pending I always recommend
working with a bigger company than just
some tiny little shop because what I
want my patent attorney to do is help
introduce me to that big company ok
understand that patent lawyers the big
ones they don't make a lot of money off
of you right you're your single
entrepreneur you've got a single
invention you're trying to make it big
but they're not making a lot of billable
hours off of you right you don't have a
lot of money to spend on legal fees
they're bigger fish come from selling
these big companies and working out big
deals with them so what I try to do is
find the company that will do my patent
that somehow connected to this big
company that I want to sell into and see
if they'd be willing to help make that
introduction for me write that patent
lawyer himself or herself may not know
somebody at Microsoft but somebody in
his or her company does and they can
make that introduction for you
especially make them look good right if
you can really help this big company out
and they're the lawyers bringing it to
that big company they look like a hero
and they get a lot more billable hours
off so you want to find ways to get
connected personally into that big
company the second thing is kick up a
lot of noise can you want to kick up a
lot of noise and get noticed in your
industry right you want people to be
blogging about you you want to be in the
media you want great testimonials you
want tons of word-of-mouth happening you
want a big user base right you want to
not just be running this business in
isolation you need people to know about
it
because big companies they have people
whose responsibility is to know what's
happening in the market right you want
to make it seem so that everywhere they
go they're seeing you they're hearing
people talk about you said what is this
company we've got to check it a little
bit more and the more noise you kick off
the more attention you're gonna get when
I had my first software company that was
one of my main responsibilities right
then we had great software and we ended
up getting bought out by a big company
and we ended up selling our software to
big companies like NASA and Johnson
Johnson huge companies
and part of what really helped was the
PR campaign that I went on right so when
I joined nobody really knew much about
the company the part of my role was
going out and doing a lot of media right
not just media talking about what our
software could do but also featuring my
partner my and the co-founder as a
champion in the space right just kicking
up a lot of noise getting getting the
software reviewed getting this the
distribution agreements get any people
that help spread the word getting
bloggers to talk about it right you need
people to pay attention to what you're
all about and the big company will start
to get noticed if you are not on their
radar then it's gonna be a lot harder to
get that deal so those are my two bits
of advice for you get connected and kick
up a lot of noise believe those are
watching like the video click on the
support me link below to help support
these videos leave a comment let me know
you think and click on my face subscribe
to the channel thank you so much I'll
see you soon